okay next I'm very pleased to introduce
our speaker today Danielle cat uh
Danielle Katz is a chi Chief scientist
at National Center for computing
applications a research associate
professor in computer science and an
electrical and Computer Engineering and
in information sciences and a faculty
affiliate in computational science and
engineering at the University of
Illinois
Urbana-Champaign he is also a better
scientific software bssw fellow
Dan's interest is in the development and
use of advanced cyber infrastructure to
solve challenging problems at multiple
scales with technical research interests
are in applications algorithms fault
tolerance and programming in parallel
and distributed computing including HPC
grid cloud and other platforms he is
also interested in policy issues
including citation and credit mechanisms
and practices associated with software
and data organization and Community
practices for collaboration and career
paths for computing researchers he
receives his BS Ms and PhD degrees in
electrical engineering from Northwestern
University in Evanston Illinois in 1988
1990 and 1994 respectively his work is
documented in numerous book chapters
journal and Conference Publications and
NASA Tech Breeze he is a senior member
of the IEEE and ACM Co founder and
current associate editor-in-chief of the
Journal of Open Source software
co-founder of the U.S research software
engineer Association and co-founder and
steering committee chair of the research
software Alliance
okay so without further Ado oh also for
questions we'll take them at the end
um yeah so just keep them in mind uh but
yeah I'll hand it off to Daniel so
there you go
okay well thank you thanks very much
thanks for the opportunity to to do this
uh for the people that are here in this
meeting for people that are watching on
YouTube separately
um so yeah so as you heard uh there's
there's a bunch of things that I'm
interested in related to software and
this talk is trying to combine a number
of them and uh and put them together in
the context of making research software
more sustainable because I feel like
that's really the uh the goal that I'm
actually interested in the end is how do
we how do we take the Investments that
we make in research software and make
that software more useful and have less
duplication and more collaboration
so um having said that then let me let
me go ahead and start
um so I I think that in general people
scientists researchers I'm going to use
science a fair bit but I don't actually
just mean science I really mean
scholarship
um I want to collaborate and so I would
say open science is the the free sharing
of scientific ideas methods and results
as as I was saying before it's not
really just science it's in German is
visenshaft but we don't have a good word
in English for this thing that's kind of
science but more than science
um and in this collaboration initially
was done via people writing letters to
each other and then writing books and
those books were mostly for other
scientists and then we got into about
400 years ago the idea of printed
journals and that expanded the audience
of who could understand who could
collaborate and then as digitalization
happened that expanded opportunities for
sharing as well as expanding what could
be shared not just printed materials but
not just words but other things
so we also have the democratization of
research and and its Public Funding as
well as information sharing like through
bulletin boards and the web and other
things and and those have also expanded
the community and made it easier to
share
um and we have this idea that knowledge
is a common good a societal good that I
think a lot of people would agree with
um I've been trying to understand where
this open science term came from and as
far as I could tell it appeared first in
science in 1882
um but that open science at that point
really meant the scientific method or
what we would call a scientific method
today it didn't really mean what we
would call open science today it seems
like open science in its modern sense
came around in the mid 1980s as best I
know and um and it seems like the the
aaas project on secrecy and openness and
Science and Technology in 1984 was
really the thing that that started this
modern movement of open science or at
least identified it and gave it a name
so even though we do want to collaborate
we also compete and that's because we
live in capitalist Societies in general
and economics really drives Our Lives
um it it drives where we work in terms
of hiring how we support ourselves in
terms of promotion how we actually get
funding to to do science to do
scholarship in terms of support and
recognition
what science we actually do often tends
to be in areas that we think will lead
to reward whether that's explicit or
implicit and what students we work with
um also really is dependent on economics
and so economics can be defined as the
science of allocating scarce resources
to maximize the achievement of computing
ends but this doesn't always hold
particularly in in science because some
resources can be increased uh digital
resources for example without them
without really having a scarcity
uh so so people then are kind of caught
between these two things of competition
and collaboration and we can think of
Engagement as the way that people join
together in in groups
um to to collaborate with competition
also kind of in the background and so we
can think of Engagement then as
meaningful and valuable actions that
produce a measurable result
this is the idea of choosing when and
where to come together to do something
and engagement then can be defined in
terms of motivation and support minus
friction where motivation has two halves
it has an intrinsic part that's all the
things that are internal to yourself
plus an extrinsic part which is things
that are external to yourself your job
your rewards your recognition your
relationships things like that
support is what makes it easier to
engage the relevantness relevance
timeliness value and friction are things
that make it harder like technology
problems user interfaces time access
lack of knowledge
so again I think the the main point here
is that
um there are ways that we can Define
engagement with there are ways that we
can Define collaborations and there's
things that we can try to increase and
things we can try to decrease if we want
to uh to increase engagement
um if we're thinking about this uh this
other side competition and why we don't
collaborate
um there's a bunch of different reasons
one of them is that sharing our work
takes effort and the immediate benefit
of that effort goes to other people that
we share with right there's a long-term
benefit to ourselves but it's not
necessarily an immediate benefit
people are often embarrassed about the
details for example their coding
practices and that leads them to say
that they don't want to share their code
because they don't want people to see
their code
sometimes it's because you don't want to
support others and you've built some
code that would be useful to others but
you're afraid if you give it to them
they'll ask you questions and you'll
have to spend time helping them
the mechanisms of sharing are new and
they're not the way we've worked
traditionally metrics for evaluating
products can be shared or underdeveloped
so we don't really have good reward
system is built yet around this
there's intellectual property laws that
are somewhat counterproductive to
collaboration and sharing often
there's commercial entities who profit
from restricting access to materials
that otherwise could be shared
um and then there's also non-profit
scientific societies that basically are
really dependent on Journal subscription
fees to support themselves and the work
that they do and so they also have an
incentive not to give things away for
free but to have some charge for things
that that helps them do other good
activities
so um having said that in general diving
into research software specifically a
little bit the reason that we care about
research software at least the reason I
care about it
um is because it's important and we can
find that importance in three different
areas one is to look at funding where we
can see things like 20 of NSF projects
over an 11-year period topically
discussed software in their abstracts
203 Main areas in the department of
energy exascale Computing program really
are research software activities and
this is probably four to five billion
dollars of investment
and about 300 million dollars of NIH
projects in the most recent fiscal year
that I could get data for included
software development as part of the
project
we can also look at Publications and we
can see that software intensive projects
are a majority of current Publications
and the most cited papers are either
methods papers or their software papers
and you can often think of software as
the implementation of a method and then
finally we can just ask researchers and
when we've asked researchers in the US
and the UK we find that 90 use research
software about two-thirds say that they
wouldn't be able to do their research
without it and about 50 develop software
as part of their research so so I think
the argument that I'm trying to make is
that software is important to research
has seen in funding as seen in
Publications and is seen by just asking
researchers
so what is this research software then
there's a few different ways we can
Define it one is that research software
is a component of instruments another is
that research software actually is the
instrument itself
a third is that research software is the
thing that allows you to analyze
research data
fourth is the research software is the
way that you present research results
another is that research software is the
the glue that assembles or integrates
existing components into a whole another
one is that research software is
infrastructure or it's an underlying
tool that gets used to to do research
and then there's research software
facilitating distinctly research
oriented collaborations so a means of
collaborating
um so if we want to think then about
kind of how do we put all these things
together into a vision about research
and research software I would say that
that vision would be that all research
software that can be is open that all
research software is high quality and
robust that all research software is
findable accessible and usable and it's
actually used by others for their own
research and it's cited when it's used
that all contributors to research
software are recognized for their work
and that they have good careers
and then all research software is
sustained as long as it's useful
and finally that all research is
reproducible
so all of these things have overlaps
particularly in terms of incentives and
policies and all of them start with
recognition of research software so this
I I would say is the the vision that I'm
trying to work towards in a number of
aspects and I feel like it also is the
vision that a lot of other people are
working towards at least parts of it and
overlapping parts that we can work on
together
so one of the problems then is software
collapse and the issue here is that
software stops working eventually if
it's not actively maintained
the computational science software
Stacks that are used generally have a
similar structure where we have on the
bottom non-scientific infrastructures
things like operating systems and
compilers and support code on top of
that is a scientific infrastructure and
that's things like libraries and
utilities that are used across many
disciplines
on top of that then it's discipline
specific software like tools and
libraries that Implement disciplinary
methods and models and on top of that
then as early project or question or
investigation specific software that's
the software that does a computation
using building blocks from those other
levels often in the form of scripts or
workflows or notebooks as well as small
special purpose libraries and utilities
and the issue is that the software in
the stack builds and depends on all the
software on all the layers below it and
any change that happens below it can
cause the software to collapse so if the
operating system changes then everything
else may need to be adapted in some way
to deal with that new operating system
for example
so this leads then to challenges one of
them is that research software is
primarily developed and used for the
purpose of research to generate process
analyze results within the scholarly
process as I mentioned before
it's increasingly essential to the
overall research process as was shown by
funding and Publications and researchers
but there are these challenges that we
have that software collapses if it's not
actively maintained software bugs are
found new features are needed new
platforms arise
the software development and maintenance
is human intensive we don't know how to
automate this and people actually just
have to dig in and do it
um and then there's also human
challenges which is that a lot of the
software that's developed for research
is developed by researchers and these
researchers know they're disciplined
really well but they often don't know
software best practices and they're not
rewarded for software development and
maintenance at least not in Academia
and then finally the developers who we
have don't match the diversity of our
overall Society or even of user
communities so there's a lot of people
that get left out and don't don't have
an opportunity to get involved and and
create new ideas and new software
so if I put this together then I'm going
to Define software sustainability as
just the fact that the software endures
and the questions on the go along with
that is will the software continue to be
available in the future on new platforms
meeting new needs
and this can only be measured in
hindsight we can say that sulfur has
been sustained we cannot say that
software will be sustained or that the
software is sustainable in the future
again software development maintenance
requires active human effort that human
effort can sometimes be transferred or
correspond to to money but not exactly
we can have projects that are entirely
based on human effort and that's things
like Community open source projects we
know those can work
we can have projects that are entirely
based on money salary commercial
software Grant funded projects for
example we know those work it's really
hard to combine these two though because
effort is not actually equal to money
and people are not purely rational so if
you have a project that has grant
funding for some developers and then you
ask for volunteers to also work on the
project those volunteers may ask why
other people are getting funded and
they're not for example so how this
actually gets put together is a
challenging problem that we don't really
have the right answers for yet
again to Define research software
sustainability in more words it's the
process of developing and maintaining
software that continues to meet its
purpose over time which includes the
software ads New capabilities as needed
by its users responds to bugs and other
problems that are discovered and is
important to work with new versions of
the underlying layers which include
software as well as new hardware
so that's really what I want to try to
address is how do we actually do this
how do we actually make research
software sustainable
some potential Solutions are that we can
try to do things that reduce the amount
of work that's needed to to do these
pieces to to fix bugs to Port software
to new platforms to add features
we can do things that increase the
amount of available resources we can try
to bring in more funding more volunteers
more
more automated methods
and we can do things that both do they
do both of those that reduce the amount
of work and increase the available
resources those are basically the three
options that we have and there's a bunch
of different things that we can put into
each of these options
so in in the first one if we want to try
to reduce the amount of work that's
needed one thing we can do is to train
developers better and this involves
finding and developing training material
and so the carpentries is an example of
an organization that produces such
material there's also discipline
specific materials and language specific
materials
we can try to use best practices which
involves finding or developing those
best practices and again software
carpentry has some ideas on this and
there are incubators that do this as
well esip and Apache for example or
organizations that have incubators for
research software development
if we want to increase the amount of
available resources one thing we can do
is to create incentives so that people
want to work on the software to increase
the number of volunteers
we can think about things like citations
that help in existing career paths I'm
going to talk about that in one of three
topics that I'll get into in a couple of
minutes
we can think about adjusting existing
career paths so that they better reward
software work whether those are post-doc
staff faculty people in National Labs
people in Industry people in government
we can think about new career paths and
I'm going to talk about this in the
second of these three new topics in a
couple of minutes
we can also increase the amount of
available funding and we could do that
by making the role of software and
research clear to research funders
whether those are government agencies
philanthropies or industry
and then clearly making the case for
them to increase funding for new
software and to provide funding for
software maintenance and if this is
government or philanthropies they're
probably doing this for the common good
if it's industry they're doing it
because it's going to help them do
whatever they're trying to do better
we can also think about seeking
institutional resources so for example
if we have software that's developed at
my institution and NCSA in Illinois
if we can make an argument that that
software is can sufficiently important
to NCSA either operationally or
reputationally then I can try to argue
for internal funds being used to help
maintain it
and then finally if we're thinking about
both producing work and bringing in new
resources one good way to do that is
trying to encourage collaboration
um and if you can use the work of others
rather than re-implementing something
yourself that reduces what you have to
do even without assuming that the
collaborators are going to come in
potentially and help you which which
also may happen
um if others are using uh your software
and contributing to maintaining it then
you have less work that you need to do
there's the other the other side of this
but in order to make this work software
has to be developed from the beginning
to be modular and reusable which is
really hard and it also has to be
clearly documented and explained to
potential users even those in fields
other than the developers and this is
maybe even harder
the software team also then has to put
effort into engaging and working with a
potential user and contributor community
and this is something that a lot of
software developers don't see as
something that's necessarily appealing
to them they want to focus on the
software and not the users so we need
people that are interested in both sides
so overall a way to do this then is to
make the software findable accessible
interoperable and reusable and and fair
is the acronym that goes along with us
and then that's the third thing that I'm
going to talk about as we as we go
forward and a third out of three so to
go into the first one then about
citation
um in 20 uh sorry
20 15 to 16.
um we started a working group on
software citation
and in that group we documented the
differences between software and data
because data citation was already
starting to take off and we defined a
set of software citation challenges
and we did that in two different
documents and then we ended up over that
two-year period creating a set of
software citation principles and
Publishing those principles
and those principles are first
importance that the software should be
considered an important and citable
product of research second credit and
attribution that the purpose of software
citations is to facilitate giving credit
and attribution in a scholarly way
third unique identification that the
software citation should include a
method that is a machine actionable
globally unique and interoperable and
recognized by a community
fourth persistence that the software
citation should endure even if the
software itself isn't that the
identifiers in the metadata are a long
lasting
fifth accessibility that part of the
purpose of a software citation is that
it actually gives you access to the
software itself and the metadata tied to
it and six specificity that the software
citation should facilitate
identification of an action to the
specific version of the software that
was used not just the generic name of
the software overall
so having then having done that and
built those principles we started
another working group in 2017 that's
really just wrapping up now called the
software citation implementation working
group and what we thought we were going
to do was to write out a little bit of
detail that was needed to actually
Implement those principles and then to
coordinate some work going on to do that
and to work with communities that wanted
to do this
and we quickly realized that that small
amount of detail wasn't actually small
and that making scattered progress
wasn't sufficient and that the
underlying challenges weren't being
addressed so we wrote another basically
document to to try to lay out what all
those challenges are in terms of
implementation and they include things
about the complexity of software types
and identifiers and where metadata is
stored as well as Social Challenges that
are basically the groups need to work on
implementation in their own context and
they need to run Pilots that establish
Norms in those contexts and then come
together and make those Norms more
General across different communities
so in response to the challenges we've
done a bunch of different work we had a
guidance task force that produced a
guidance document for paper authors who
want to cite software and for software
developers who want to make their
software citable
we had a task force working in a project
called codeneta code meta is a project
that was trying to understand metadata
for software it built a crosswalk of
existing metadata standards and then
developed its own standard to describe
software based on the kind of the Union
of those crosswalks in some sense
the task force updated the code meta
standard it's described everything in
code meta using schema.org properties
and it's basically turning code meta
into a community group with governance
and turning the actual metadata part
into schema.org so it's standardized and
we don't have to worry about that part
we also worked on Registries the places
that software gets deposited and we
created a best practices document for
software Registries and repositories
that want to hold software and turn that
into a community that is continuing in a
group called cycodes and that's a
Consortium of scientific software
Registries and repositories that's open
for anybody to join that's interested
the journals task force that we ran
worked with Publishers to provide them
with generic guidelines and they could
then turn those generic guidelines into
specific guidelines for their journals
and conferences and their communities
that used Community accepted language
and Community accepted examples
we published that as a document with a
bunch of different Publishers as
co-authors and there's an industry
publisher group called chorus that is
tracking the different software citation
policies from a set of different
Publishers at this point in updating it
at least once a year
we're also working on publication
processing and this is almost done but
not quite done which is effectively when
you submit a paper and you have a
citation of software you're putting it
in some format eventually it has to go
through a bunch of different processing
and get to an index that helps the
software producer understand who cited
their software and that process has some
problems right now and we're trying to
provide some guidance for journals that
help them fix those problems and make
this process work more smoothly so that
people who develop software actually can
count the citations and understand how
their software is being used
and then finally we considered an
institutions test course with the idea
being institutions are places where
people work like universities the goal
of this task force would have been to
affect policies and practices within
those institutions how they encourage
software citation how they use citation
information hiring and promotion to
collect and share examples to help form
communities but we didn't have enough
interest to actually do this so this is
kind of on hold at this point
and then finally we had an activity that
tried to look at all of this last summer
and tried to say what have we done and
what else needs to be done who can do it
and there was a workshop in in Boston
last summer that addressed this and
there's a report available
as of May of this year earlier this
month we've completed the working group
with the community is interested in
continued discussion and we're currently
writing a blog post to suggest topics
and venues for that continued discussion
to happen
um I should have mentioned earlier
there's a DOI at the bottom of all these
slides and and all these links that are
in the slides you can click on if you
get the slides from that DUI
okay so since I was talking about
citation I also just want to briefly
mention the Journal of Open Source
software Joss Joss is a developer
friendly journal for research software
packages we say if you've already
licensed your code and have good
documentation it should take less than
an hour to prepare and submit your paper
everything about Jaws is open the
submitted and published papers are
entirely open access free to free to
submit free to review free to read where
the code is itself is up to the authors
the review process is also completely
open it's uh
authors know their viewers the reviewers
know the authors the editors know both
um and the code for the journal itself
is also open source so if you want to
create your own version of a journal
like this you can do this this code has
been reused for the Journal of Open
Source education and it's also what's
used for the proceedings of the Julia
cotton conferences
what you can see here is that we've been
growing in terms of the number of papers
published since we started
um sorry I shouldn't I should say that
these the Joss papers are archived they
have DOI as they're cited the first
paper was submitted in 2016 at the
beginning of this chart
in 2017 we had a year later we had about
110 accepted papers and 50 under review
as of a couple of weeks ago we had a
little over 2 000 papers accepted and
about 230 that were currently in review
current publication rate as you can see
is about one a day about 30 a month but
we're kind of slowly growing we were
growing quite quickly until the pandemic
where there's kind of a gap where we
shut things down for a little while and
then when we reopened we've had a much
slower growth since then
uh when we started we had an
editor-in-chief and 11 editors and today
we have one editor-in-chief seven
Associates and track editors in Chief
and one of those uh 69 editors and 35
editors who have finished terms and have
stepped down
uh Joss is also a community
um and so it's interesting to think
about how cultures change and this is
often based on a combination of rules
and incentives
Joss practices I believe have influenced
reviewers and developers in terms of
thinking about what's good and what's
minimally acceptable this is similar to
what our opencide has done in the r
community and for Joss the minimum
criteria for successful review has
changed over time as Community best
practices have developed so our
guidelines on packaging and testing in
CI and documentation have gotten
stricter over the the seven years that
we've been doing this now
we also are applying open source
software practices effectively to how we
run the journal so we're trying to make
the all the processes as open and
collaborative as possible
and so Joss effectively is providing
rules about software and at a high level
is trying to nudge incentives by giving
a reward for publishing software
uh we like the the accepted papers and
Joss to effectively be seen as accepted
papers and the rest of the scholarly
system so faculty members and others get
credit for their software in the same
way they would get credit for a paper
um it's worth mentioning if the software
is being cited directly which is what I
was arguing we want to move towards
previously uh Joss papers actually
wouldn't be needed but the Joss review
process and the Joss Community would
still have great value and so we'd have
to to figure out a little bit of a way
to uh to to have reviews applied to saf
to software that's not a paper but I
think we may be able to do that and then
maybe where we're going in a few years
okay so the second topic then is on
Career paths and research software
engineers
um research software again comes from
research in in large part
um it seems like this has happened from
the beginning Computing as far as I can
tell and I'm eager to hear of other
opinions and correct slides for the
future I think
software has appeared around 1948. it
seems like research software appeared
just a couple years later first in
weather in the early 1950s the idea of
software engineering seemed to start in
the late 1960s and it was mostly
initially applied to operation software
like operating systems and NASA flights
for example
um as I mentioned earlier again the
researchers often faculty for example
generally don't really know good
software practices there that's not what
their expertise is in we have software
Engineers who do know good software
practices but they generally don't
understand the context of research
and then we have students and postdocs
that are kind of in the middle in some
sense they generally don't start off
knowing good software practices or their
research area but by the time they
understand both reasonably well they
generally graduate and they go somewhere
else
sometimes postdocs do stay around and
sometimes they join the staff of an
institution like a university sometimes
they're officially considered staff
sometimes they're just considered a
postdoc for a really really long long
time
but overall we do get to the point where
we get staff who have a research
understanding and software engineering
skills and they develop over time in a
lot of institutions
so we can think about this then in terms
of differences between the craftsperson
and the scholar a scholar is a an
architical researcher who's driven to
understand things to their fullest
capability they work on intellectually
demanding problems and they do it in a
curiosity driven way they work on a
topic until they have enough
understanding of it and they typically
pass that understanding on through
teaching or through documentation or
through writing a paper about it
uh the craftsperson on the other hand is
somebody that's driven to create and
leave behind an artifact that really
explains what they've done that
represents what they've done they feel
pain when they make things that are
fragile or ugly they prefer to make
things and explain themselves well and
they do work that requires patience and
have pride in doing their job well
scientific software requires people who
combine the best of both of these roles
and I'll just mention this is from a
Blog that was written in 2012 and this
is really when this idea kind of started
about research software engineers
and so research software engineers then
you can think of as uh you know existing
in a space where software engineering is
one access and research as the other
access and we have traditional software
Engineers who are really strong in
software engineering but not necessarily
in research we have really strong
researchers who are good at research but
not necessarily software engineering
we have a bunch of people who are
researcher developers who are quite good
at research and are okay at software
engineering and can get by
um but the idea is that we have research
software Engineers who are really more
in the middle here and have better
software engineering experience but
understand research as well and this is
kind of a cloud it's not there's not a
single place that they sit but they're
kind of somewhere in this middle space
in 2012 there was a workshop in the UK
called the collaborations workshop and
what they discovered is that there were
already a lot of people at their
universities the universities that met
uh doing this kind of work that were
doing this work that today we would call
research software engineering but they
had no common title they looked and they
discovered there were 194 different job
titles they could find for people that
were basically doing that same work
and so they decided research software
engineer would be the title that they
would come together on it wasn't
necessarily the one that everybody
thought was the best one but it was the
one that everybody agreed was good
enough to go forward with
they decided that there wasn't really
any Community these people didn't really
know each other very well and so they
started forming uh initially an
association in the UK which has turned
into a society in the UK and a bunch of
other associations and Societies in
other parts of the world
and this wasn't a profession and so this
group decided to start thinking about
career paths and structures to turn it
into a profession
so in the the 10 plus years that we've
had research software Engineers again
this the idea of this was born in the UK
and by late 2013 the UK research
software engineering Association had
formed with about 50 members it's now a
professional Society with about 700 dues
paying members and about 4 600 members
overall
there also are similar associations in
Belgium and Germany and the Netherlands
and the Nordic countries Australia and
New Zealand uh and there's one in the
U.S as well usrse which has about 1700
members currently across University as
National Labs and Industry and there's
new associations forming in Africa and
Asia today
these associations work on local issues
collectively and then they can
coordinate across associations when
there's really when there are Global
issues as well and just to kind of show
what this looks like we've got now a
bunch of countries that have these red
associations and we have these kind of
more pink areas where there is work
going on and then we have gray areas
where we need to do more work to kind of
spread this message and spread this
community
the advantages of research software
Engineers are that they lead to better
software and more mature project
management aspects and structures
they lead to ideas about team
organization and work organization and
software organization and coding
practices and try to standardize those
in in projects and professionalize them
and this then ideally leads to better
and more sustainable code and more
efficient group coordination
they also lead to institutional memory
because research software is becoming
more important and complex and costly
the expertise about it is valuable and
rses as somebody in the University or an
institution staff have longevity Beyond
individual projects and students
and they're often also mobile across
different disciplines and domains so
they can translate knowledge and
artifacts across communities and take
practices that work in one area and
bring them into another area
they also build community expertise
because rses typically work on Grant
funded projects and those projects
typically have one less than one
full-time equivalent RSE in them these
projects have a shorter duration than
staff careers and this leads to some
kind of Matrix management with RSE
groups often where there's a pi access
that changes over time and is funded by
the different projects and then there's
a group manager axis which is fixed and
funded by overhead or taxes on projects
or the institutions but effectively this
leads to people in a place where they
can have somebody that's concerned about
their career and somebody that's
concerned about their project and they
can work on both and grow in both over
time
this leads then to a pool of experts and
expertise in an RSE group and these RSC
groups typically welcome others with
shared earn so Stephen if they're not in
the group like grad students faculty
others who are just interested in making
their software better for research
okay and then the last thing that I'm
going to talk about is fair for research
software
so in 2016 an article was written about
the fair guiding principles for
scientific data management and
stewardship
and this article on these principles
were intended to ensure that data
are shared in a way that enables and
enhances reuse by humans and machines a
uh quite a lot of local
and the principles are in four parts
there's findable how the how data is
made findable
which talks about things related to the
data itself as well as the metadata
about the data things about accessible
which is how do you actually access the
data and again there's questions about
the data itself as well as the metadata
uh interoperable how can you use the
metadata and the data with other
metadata and data how to use kind of
common practices to describe it
um and then reusable which is that you
have enough attributes about the data
and the metadata that you can you can
get to it you understand it you know
where it's come from and it meets
Community standards
um and this is uh partly because it's an
idea that caught on partly because it's
a clever acronym it has become uh quite
accepted in a lot of different
governments and a lot of different uh
communities that data should be fair
um if we think about Fair Beyond data
these principles at a high level say
that they are intended to apply to all
research objects both those used in
research and those that are research
outputs
as I mentioned before and kind of showed
you the text and those principles often
includes meta and parentheses data and
that's shorthand from metadata and data
because people writing this wanted to be
very concise
the principles themselves are applied
via data set creators and repositories
you can think somebody creates a data
set they give it and some metadata to a
repository the repository then makes it
findable and accessible
um and so the the creators and the
repositories together are responsible
for creating the annotating indexing
preserving and sharing the data sets in
their metadata
um as I kind of hinted this assumes that
there are separate and sequential roles
between the Creator and the publisher or
the repository right somebody builds the
data set they turn it over to a
publisher repository the publisher
repository shared
but if we think about objects that
aren't data
um they can often be stored as data but
they're not just data thinking of
software as an example
the the high level goals of making let's
say software findable accessible
interoperable reusable are the same but
the details and how they're actually
implemented depend on how those objects
are created and used thinking of
software being let's say written as open
source or written by a company
where the software is stored and shared
and how the metadata and where the
metadata is stored and indexed about the
software
so that seems to imply that there's work
that's needed to Define and Implement an
adopt these data principles for other
kinds of objects software for example
um as I said before the fair principles
are intended to apply to all kinds of
digital objects but the es test course
in the European Union in 2020 had a set
of six recommendations one of them was
to recognize that fair guidelines will
require translation for other digital
objects and support such efforts and the
French National Committee for open
Sciences free software and open source
project group specifically said to to
that software has a nature that is
different than data that software is not
just data and then we need to work on it
differently
so what uh our working group did was to
focus on the adaption and adoption
adaptation and Adoption of the fair
principles to research software
um and the reason again is that software
is not just data it's executable where
data is not executable data in general
provides evidence where software
provides a tool software is a creative
work and scientific data in a very
general sense our facts are observations
you may be aware that software can be
copyrighted in scientific data as data
cannot be copyrighted they end up
leading to having different licensing
and copyright practices around they're
treated different legally
software software suffers from software
collapse where data really just has the
issues that the bits may not be readable
uh the lifetime of software is generally
not as long as that of data although
that's not always the case and one of
the big issues is that for open source
software there's no natural sequential
Creator and publisher process as there
is for data and there's no national
natural publisher if you're building
software in GitHub for example there's
not really a publisher where you declare
you're done and then somebody else takes
it and they're responsible for it it's
it's kind of always you
um the whole time GitHub may may help
you but GitHub also is not archival and
it's owned by Microsoft who provides it
as a service but it may go away in the
same way that previous repositories have
gone away
so the fair for research software group
then was a working group that defined a
set of consensus Fair principles for
research software there were nine of us
that led this group and we did this
under three different organizations
Force 11 which is a group that focuses
on Research communication and
e-scholarship the research data Alliance
that focuses on data and the research
software Alliance that focuses on
software
we first had to Define research software
in this context and and what we did was
to say that it includes source code
files algorithms scripts computational
workflows and executables that were
created during the research process or
for research purpose
there are additional software components
like operating systems and libraries and
other things that are used in research
but were not created during or with a
research intent and we would call those
software in research but not research
software
and this differentiation varies between
disciplines so just for example I've
said that the operating system is
typically research in software but not
research software sorry it's typically
software in research but not research
software but if you're a computer
scientist doing work in operating
systems then your operating system is
research software for you even though it
may not be for a computational chemist
that's going to use it as a product
later so it's a little bit tricky to
Define this
the fearful research software principles
that were published last year
are at a high level similar to the fair
principles for data I'm here writing
them out and I'm using italics to
indicate that things are different and
I'm going to just talk about those
briefly and not talk about the things
that aren't in italics so in terms of
findability one of the two of the real
issues here are related to identifiers
and the fact that there is both both the
versioning that happens in software in a
way that's different from data and
granularity that happens in software
that's in a way that's different than
data if you think about software you
could think about a project a project
has versions The those versions have
source code they have issues they may
have design documents the source code
may be in files maybe in directories
first and then files and each file may
be thought of as having lines or tokens
or something else so there's a lot of
different levels of granularity that you
may want to identify
in terms of accessibility there's really
no no real differences other than uh
just saying software and metadata rather
than rather than metadata in terms of
interoperability there are a lot of
differences and and this is really a
completely different idea and what we've
chosen to say is that software
interoperates with other software
through exchanging data or metadata or
through interaction through apis that
are described in standards and that we
want to make sure that those things are
done in standard ways for communities
and that they are referenced
appropriately
and in terms of reusability we have the
issue that software or usability
might be that it can be executed and
that's important to start with and
reusability might be that somebody else
can understand it they can read it they
can modify it they can build on it or
they can incorporate it into other
software as well as they can execute it
so that means that software is dependent
on other software and that that
dependency is really a difference from
software to data
so so these principles were published
we've turned the governance of this
activity the interpretation of the
principles and future revisions over to
a different group the research data
Alliance software source code interest
group
we've published a survey of adoption
guidelines from organizations that are
interested as well as studying how those
organizations are doing this and why
they're doing it
um and we're left with the issue that
that fair for research software exposes
some of the same ecosystem gaps that we
talked about for a citation uh related
to metadata archiving and versioning as
I said before the Creator and publisher
sequence doesn't really apply often for
open source we don't necessarily know
where metadata should be stored if it's
in the code repository itself for open
source but if it's for closed Source
software where is it and and do we use
archival repositories or do we use
Registries where code is archived is
also a challenge as I mentioned before
GitHub and gitlab are not archival they
don't have any preservation aspect to
them we have Registries that are not
archival as well we have repository is
there something called software Heritage
which is interesting to look at if you
haven't seen it that's kind of like the
internet archive for open source
software
that's aimed at trying to preserve a
version of all changes of all open
source software overall time
and then we have the fact that different
use cases for software require
potentially a specific version or the
latest version or all versions depending
on what level of granularity you're
interested in and what you're trying to
do
so there's also a lot of work Beyond
fair right fair is findable accessible
interoperable reusable again it doesn't
say anything about the quality of the
software it doesn't say anything about
the correctness of the software or the
reproducibility of the work done with
the software or even the openness of the
software
so just to kind of close wrap up having
talked about those three things I do
want to just briefly mention the
research software Alliance as a context
activity and is something that you may
be interested in getting involved in
uh research software Alliance has a
vision that research software and those
who develop it and maintain it are
recognized and valued as fundamental and
vital and vital to research worldwide
and the mission of reso then is to
advance the research software ecosystem
by collaborating with key influencers
and decision makers
it was founded in 2019 it's a fiscally
sponsored project by code for Science
and Society
and it recently has been involved in
co-developing the fair principles I
talked about and talking about diversity
equity and inclusion best practices in
doing a global mapping of the
international research software
Community landscape and then recently
expanding it in gathering Global
Research software funders together to
set an agenda for what sustainable
research software means for them and how
they can address that and that's led to
a draft declaration called a door.s
software that we hope will be signed
towards the end of this year a
declaration on funding research software
sustainability signed by research
software funders
as well as having collaboration uh Risa
having collaboration and specific issues
that address the Global Research
community
so if you're interested in this you can
sign up to receive the recent newsletter
you can join the recess slack you can
add to a database that we have of open
funding calls for research software
and you can join task forces that are
focused on specific activities
so having said all that a little bit
quickly just to try to wrap up
where we are now is that research
software is increasingly important to
research citation is the accepted
mechanism for scholarly Credit in
Academia and software citation is
beginning to be accepted with uptake
from researchers Publishers Librarians
Etc
software papers are partially a
placeholder for software citation but
they also have an important Community
function
research software Engineers have been
recently recognized as an official role
but there's a long history of people
doing this work from long before it had
a name
and we're now building Community around
this and making a case within various
institutions and funders for formal
career paths
the fair data principles set out a good
goal to share data to enable and enhance
reuse but there's work needed to apply
this to research software both open
source and then closed source to fulfill
the open science Concepts we've created
a set of principles with about 500
people involved in about 60 different
events and there's now work underway to
create guidance adopt those principles
Define governance and the next steps
then will be to create metrics in in
Widen adoption
so finally to close there's things that
you can do you can promote software
sharing and credit and you can do this
by when you're an author of a paper to
be sure to cite the software that you
use
when you develop software and make it
easy to cite when you review whether
you're reviewing work for a journal for
a conference for a funding proposal a
demand that software be cited in those
documents that you're reviewing
and work to make your own software Fair
follow the fair principles as much as
you can
you can support research software
engineers
you can do this by just supporting the
software and developers and software
developers and maintainers in your own
organization and think about how your
organization does this and and see if
there's a way that you can change it if
you're involved in uh in reviewing
somebody's promotion case reviewing
hiring you're in a hiring committee
things like that
think about how software is being
recognized in those activities and try
to raise it as an issue that should be
or should be considered
and usrc and the Society of RSA in the
UK are places that you can go to talk
about this and work with others
as I said you can work to make sure that
software work is included in hiring and
promotion
all of these activities are open
communities open science open software
fair for research software although that
one's really finished now citation which
is kind of finishing as well the RSE
community in Risa so you can join one of
these communities
and finally you can try to raise the
awareness of research software as a key
element of research research software is
not business software it has different
goals it has different incentives it has
different methods different practices
different Workforce different education
uh when people talk about software you
can highlight the fact that research
software is is important and it really
is a key element of research
and so with that I will end by just
giving some some credits
uh Arvin Smith and Kyle Niemeyer and I
co-led the initial software citation
working group arfin is also the
editor-in-chief of Joss Neil chuhang and
Martin Fenner worked with me in
co-leading the software citation
implementation working group there's a
bunch of different people that have been
involved in RSC discussions with me over
time a bunch more people that have been
involved in the fair for research
software work and then finally a bunch
of other people that have made me think
differently about the way I've presented
some work and the way I thought about it
and done it the better scientific
software project that was mentioned in
the introduction that's given me a
fellowship that helped me do some of the
citation work and if you're interested I
have a Blog where I'm writing less and
less frequently but still occasionally
as well as a master plan Channel that I
try to post to fairly recently and with
that I will stop and see what kind of
questions and discussions this might
lead to so thank you very much
great thank you I'm gonna stop recording
and then